[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schön dass sie dabei sind an
diesem freitagabend wir durchleben ja
eine herausfordernde corona phase alle
relevanten infos dazu bei uns in den
nächsten minuten und katja stresow
corona erregt ja auch die fußballwelt
die stimmen nach einem ruf für eine
impfpflicht für profisportler die werden
immer lauter und dann blicken wir jetzt
auf unsere themen
bayern macht dicht weihnachtsmärkte
werden abgesagt knacken geschlossen und
einige regionen gehen in den lockdown
3g am arbeitsplatz unternehmen fragen
sich wie sie die neuen regeln umsetzen
sollen
und impfpflicht in österreich als erstes
land in europa wollen unsere nachbarn
corona impfungen für alle ab februar
anordnen
trotz neuem infektionsschutzgesetz viele
experten sagen die maßnahmen kommen viel
zu spät dramatisch ist die situation in
sachsen wo zur stunde über schärfere
maßnahmen beraten wird ähnlich schlimm
in bayern die inzidenz liegt dort bei
fast 600 weswegen die landesregierung
schon am mittag die korona regeln
deutlich verschärfte schauen wir uns mal
gemeinsam an für ungeimpfte kommen
kontakt beschränkungen maximal dürfen
sich nur noch fünf personen aus zwei
haushalten treffen
sämtliche weihnachtsmärkte werden
abgesagt clubs und bars müssen für die
nächsten drei wochen schließen
in den bayerischen hotspots also den
acht landkreisen in denen die sieben
tage incidents über 1000 liegt kommt ein
lock down also das öffentliche leben
wird weitgehend herunter gefahren petra
neubauer berichtet
eleonore stiegl hat schon wieder alles
zusammengepackt auch die anderen boden
auf dem bamberger weihnachtsmarkt werden
kaum auf nun wieder abgebaut bayern sagt
alle weihnachtsmärkte ab zum entsetzen
der schausteller wir sind händler und
haben die ware eingekauft für mir auch
produziert und sitze des 2d auf
null gestellt
dieser weihnachtsmarkt ist für uns
überhaupt einheimischer weihnachtsfeier
es sind scharfe massnahmen wie der
bayerische ministerpräsident heute
verkündet und er tut dies auch mit einem
seitenhieb auf die ungeimpften wir haben
lange rücksicht auf alle ungeimpften
genommen jetzt müssen wir weniger
rücksicht nehmen auf die die selbst
keine nehmen für die ungeimpften gibt es
nun also noch mehr einschränkungen doch
die neuen regeln treffen auch andere
etwa peter flemming und seinem club in
münchen er muss ab nächster woche ganz
schließen das gilt wie alle maßnahmen
bis 15 dezember wir haben uns auf alle
regeln eingestellt wir haben zwei gibt
es jetzt mit getragen oder finden das
sogar auch richtig und werden aber jetzt
eben wieder bestraft das ist irgendwie
dass man hat das gefühl dass es eben an
der falschen stelle ist zumindest sollen
schulen und kitas offen bleiben es gilt
masken pflicht in fußballstadien oder zu
kulturveranstaltungen darf nur noch ein
viertel der möglichen zuschauer sie
müssen aber geimpft oder genießen und
getestet sein noch deutlich straffer
werden die zügel in den sogenannten
hotspot regionen angezogen also dort wo
die inzidenz über 1000 liegt hier muss
alles geschlossen werden gastro hotel
sportkultur flüsse und sünder plädiert
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
andernfalls könne corona zu einer
endlosschleife werden
wir gehen nach münchen zu patricia
schäfer patricia drastische maßnahmen
der bayerischen landesregierung wie
kommt das an entspricht das dem ernst
der lage oder wirkt das überzogen
die betroffenen dimitri fühlen sich
natürlich vor den kopf gestoßen es war
doch überraschend die schließung der
weihnachtsmärkte und der quasi lockdown
in den hot spot regionen oder beruft
sich auf den ernst der lage auf die
gestiegenen instanzen bayern hat acht
landkreise mit einer inzidenz über 1000
nochmal so viele könnten diese marke in
den nächsten tagen reißen die lage in
den krankenhäusern ist so dass bereits
diese woche nicht notwendige operationen
untersagt wurden noch können intensiv
patienten innerhalb bayerns verlegt
werden und patienten aber das wird nur
noch ein paar hagel möglich sein das
heißt es musste etwas geschehen nur
genau das hatten experten bereits im
sommer angemahnt wie der bayerische
ethikrat mediziner virologen hatten
gesagt wenn die entwicklung so
weitergeht und nichts unternommen wird
dann laufen wir in diese situation
hinein die jetzt eingetreten ist das
heißt so da hat die zügel spät angezogen
vielleicht zu spät und er hätte einiges
von dem was er jetzt beschlossen was
jetzt beschlossen wurde bereits früher
tun können dass es sind die vorwürfe die
ihm hier gemacht werden danke nach
münchen patricia schäfer in der pandemie
da gilt ja bis maßnahmen wirkungen
zeigen da dauert es ein bisschen der
trend bei den zahlen der setzt sich erst
einmal fort 52 1970 neue corona fälle
wurden heute gemeldet die inzidenz die
steigt auf 3 140,7 und erreicht damit
den zwölften tag in folge einen neuen
höchststand
lka-chef wähler warnte deswegen heute
noch einmal eindringlich vor einer
nationalen notlage ganz deutschland ist
ein einziger chor ohne ausbruch andreas
kühn aus berichtet
eigentlich hat lothar wieler keinen
superlativ mehr übrig seit 31
pressekonferenzen wiederholt der
präsident des robert koch instituts das
ist schlimm werden kann und schlimmer
heute mit einer halben million aktiver
corona fälle ist es so schlimm wie noch
nie
und bei kindern im alter von 5 bis 14 da
liegt die inzidenz bei über 700 die zahl
der schul aus größe steige ebenfalls es
geht hier schon lange nicht mehr um
einzelne ausbruchsgeschehen ganz
deutschland ist ein einziger großer
ausbruch das ist eine nationale notlagen
wieder zeigt wieder die untere linie
sind gegeben das eklatant mehr
ungeimpfte ins krankenhaus müssen wieder
kritisiert er die maßnahmen der politik
als nicht ausreichend bereits jetzt sei
die medizinische versorgung in einigen
regionen nicht mehr gewährleistet es
fehlt personal es viel zeit es fehlt
kraft
wir sind am überlegen wie können wir
personal für die intensivstation
zusammenziehen das heißt aber für die
mannschaft hier auf den
intensivstationen nochmal eine belastung
weil die auch die neuen mitarbeiter
eingelernt werden müssen wir müssen auch
denen die ängste nehmen wie hoch der
lang erwartete pflege bonus sein wird
den bund und länder gestern beschlossen
haben steht noch immer nicht fest der
scheidende gesundheitsminister macht
erstmals einen vorschlag und er muss
jetzt auch mal spürbar sein also wie man
seinen 5000 euro plus für intensivpflege
kräfte wird das was irgendwie angemessen
wäre um mal sagen und zwar nicht nur für
die pflegekräfte auf intensiv auf das
reinigungspersonal um intensivpatienten
notfalls in freie krankenhäuser zu
verlegen bereitet die bundeswehr
amtshilfe vor nach einer bitte des
kanzleramts stehen die ersten transport
kapazitäten bereit
mit 2g und 3g soll die vierte welle
gebremst werden grundlage ist das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz der ampel
parteien und dem hat heute auch der
bundesrat zugestimmt damit ist der weg
frei für flächendeckende corona regeln
wie die home office pflicht oder
testpflicht in heimen nicht mehr möglich
flächendeckende schließungen die
entscheidung fiel am ende einstimmig
kritik gab's trotzdem vor allem von den
länderchefs der union das auslaufen der
epidemischen lage sei ein fatales signal
wir fassen noch mal zusammen theo koll
in berlin corona dramatik düstere
weihnachts szenarien erste lok downs in
bayern vielleicht sogar auch sachsen
noch nach wie angemessen sind vor diesem
hintergrund die beschlüsse von bund und
ländern also ich fürchte die antwort
wird das virus geben stand heute
beurteilen politiker und virologen die
beschlüsse ja noch sehr unterschiedlich
die ampel vertreter halten das neue
instrumentarium weiterhin für
ausreichend sind damit aber quasi ab
sofort auf dem prüfstand der olaf scholz
hat die überprüfung der wirksamkeit ja
bis zum nächsten treffen der
ministerpräsidenten am 9 dezember
zugesagt inklusive möglicher
nachbesserung der union fehlt bei der
neuregelung noch immer die möglichkeit
zur ausgangssperren und pauschalen
schließungen dass bayern jetzt die
maßnahmen massiv verschärft das beruht
ja noch auf der alten gesetzesgrundlage
der epidemischen notlage die zwar
kommenden donnerstag ausläuft aber mit
einer verlängerungsfrist für schon
laufender maßnahmen bis zum 15 dezember
gilt also sollte das derzeitige
gesetzespaket sich als nicht ausreichend
erweisen dann könnte auf der nächsten
mpk noch nachgesteuert werden danke für
die einschätzung nach berlin theo koll
und wir schauen jetzt nochmal genauer
auf die korona beschlüsse von gestern
künftig soll ja die sogenannte
hospitalisierung rate maßgebend sein für
einschränkungen in den bundesländern sie
sagt aus wie viele kranke die kliniken
aufgenommen haben das klingt eigentlich
ganz einfach hat aber seine tücken wie
volker check zeigt die hospitalisierung
since i denn es gibt an wie viele
menschen pro 100000 einwohner innerhalb
von sieben tagen mit einer corona
infektion ins krankenhaus müssen
bundesweit liegt die rate heute bei 5,34
ab den schwellenwerten 3 6 und 9 müssen
künftig verschärfungen in kraft treten
unter dem wert von 3 liegen allein
hamburg und niedersachsen ab stufe drei
gilt die 2g vorschrift nur geimpfte und
genesene haben etwa zutritt zu
gastronomie hotels und veranstaltungen
das gilt für die meisten länder von
schleswig holstein bis nach
baden-württemberg und
mecklenburg-vorpommern die beide
allerdings nahe an der grenze zum
incidents wert 6 liegen ab stufe 6 gilt
landesweit zweig plus zusätzlich muss
dann ein frischer test vorgelegt werden
ab stufe 9 gelten gesonderte
anstrengungen das geht von kontakt
beschränkung bis zum veranstaltungs
verbot dazu zählen derzeit bayern
sachsen anhalt und thüringen die
hospitalisierung since it ends ist aber
nur ein ungefährer wert denn die
krankenhaus meldung werden immer noch
nicht automatisch und digital erfasst
grundsätzlich ist das der richtige wert
an dem man sich auch orientieren sollte
wie es jetzt beschlossen wurde wir haben
aber zum teil noch ein meldeverfahren
was eben hinterher hängt so dass wir
nicht jeden tag wirklich die
tagesaktuelle ratte abbilden können und
das müssen wir dringend beheben ob sich
die hospitalisierung incidents
tatsächlich als neue leitwährung eignet
wird sich wohl erst in den nächsten
wochen zeigen
wie genau die geplante 3g regelung am
arbeitsplatz umgesetzt wird werden die
nächsten wochen auch zeigen bundesweit
soll wohl ab kommenden mittwoch 3g
gelten dann dürfen nur noch geimpfte
genesene oder getestete die
arbeitsstätte betreten kontrollieren und
dokumentieren muss das dann der
arbeitgeber bei den getesteten sogar
täglich ein schnelltest den mann zu
hause selber macht reicht dabei nicht
aus wer sich weigert eine 3g nachweis
vorzulegen und somit nicht arbeiten darf
soll auch keinen anspruch auf bezahlung
haben nur fragen sich viele wie das im
alltag funktionieren kann dazu constanze
kainz
normalerweise arbeiten im büro des
start-ups flip rund 80 junge menschen
heute ist weniger los wer kann bleibt im
home-office hier setzen sich schon um
was die regierung jetzt beschlossen hat
uns ist es wichtig dass mitarbeiter sich
einfach sicher fühlen und
auch gesund bleiben das ist ein
wettbewerbsfaktor
deshalb sind wir da einfach
jemanden schuss zu streng und im
anschluss zu vorsichtig wir stellen
jeden mitarbeiter einen arbeitsplatz zu
hause zur verfügung home office beim
maschinenbauer ziel aber keine option
ein großteil der 2.400 mitarbeitenden
arbeitet in der produktion die
verschärften maßnahmen bedeuten für den
geschäftsführer vor allem stress wir
müssen jeden mitarbeiter der ins haus
kommt am morgen befragen kommen der
woche bist du geimpft bist du chinesen
bieten nachweisen bist du nicht nicht
stimmt nicht genesen bitte test
nachweisen habe ich nicht gewusst
wie machen wir es jetzt das wird sehr
sehr holprig sein kommen der woche rund
30 prozent der belegschaft seien
ungeimpfte der chef für sie soll es ab
kommender woche vor ort testen stationen
geben klar ist es muss ein
zertifizierter test seien außerdem darf
der arbeitgeber jetzt speichern mehr
genießen oder geimpft ist muss die daten
aber nach sechs monaten löschen bei den
ungeimpften mitarbeitern kommt 3g
unterschiedlich an muss mich daran
halten was die regierung vorgibt was
kann ich machen ich bin jung meine
arbeit zu machen wenn jemand urlaub
machen will muss auch das zu lassen im
arbeit das gleiche ob start up oder
großkonzern 3g für bei der arbeitgeber
eine herausforderung
noch schlimmer die korona lage in
österreich die infektionszahlen steigen
rasant und die regierung geht viel
weiter als die in deutschland
ab montag nämlich wird das öffentliche
leben komplett heruntergefahren für die
gesamte bevölkerung egal ob geimpft oder
ungeimpft und ab februar soll dann die
generelle impfpflicht kommen bisher sind
rund 66 prozent der bevölkerung
vollständig geimpft britta hilpert über
die aktuelle situation in österreich
eine nächtliche krisensitzung und eine
sieben tage instanz von über 1000 treibt
österreichs regierung zu bisher
beispiellosen maßnahmen lockdown für
alle und impfpflicht ab februar quote
nachhaltig zu erhöhen ist unser einziger
weg um aus diesem teufelskreis von virus
wellen und lockt und diskussionen
endgültig raus zu kommen ab montag drei
wochen lang darf man nur für
lebensnotwendiges raus infektionszahlen
soll das schnell drücken der locker und
verhagelt gastronomie und handel das so
wichtige vorweihnachtsgeschäft
41 sind wir jetzt praktisch voll gegen
die wand gefahren das immer gesehen was
kommt und dass es immer stärker wird
jetzt hätten heute schon viel früher die
maßnahmen gehört für schulen gibt es
eine sonderlösung eltern sollen wenn
möglich kindern fernunterricht
ermöglichen denn bei jüngeren ist die
infektionsrate besonders hoch doch
berufstätige eltern können ihre kinder
herschicken auch wollen viele schüler
das fast
30% ungeimpfte österreicher müssen sich
ab februar impfen lassen es wird dann
pflicht österreich ist das erste eu-land
mit einer corona impfpflicht wer das
impfen verweigert den drohen
verwaltungsstrafen schon morgen sind
hier in wien proteste dagegen
angekündigt tausende werden erwartet ein
potenzielles super strater ereignis auch
skifahren ist vorbei bevor es richtig
losging seilbahnen und lifte stehen ab
montag stehen
österreich steht ja schon auf der
deutschen liste mit hochrisiko gebieten
ab sonntag kommen einige länder dazu die
niederlande belgien griechenland und
irland ungeimpfte rückkehrer müssen dann
in quarantäne
frankreich wurde von der liste
gestrichen und in unserer zdf heute app
können sie alle entwicklungen nachlesen
immer mit aktuellen zahlen und
wesentliche meldungen aus dem in und
ausland
von einer chaos wahl war die rede als
die berliner im september ihre stimme
für die wahlen des bundestags und das
abgeordnetenhaus abgaben in mehreren
bezirken gab es erhebliche probleme das
hat jetzt folgen der bundeswahlleiter
hat einspruch gegen das bundes der
berliner innensenator gegen das
landesergebnis eingelegt und jetzt wird
geprüft ob die pannen einfluss auf die
mandatsverteilung hatten und ob in
diesen bezirken möglicherweise neu
abgestimmt werden muss
eine große ehre für bundespräsident
steinmeier in new york ist er mit der
leo baeck medaille ausgezeichnet worden
für sein engagement für die deutsch
jüdische versöhnung und für seine so
wörtlich große moralische klarheit in
seiner dankesrede fand steinmeier
deutliche worte wir dürfen in
deutschland keinen antisemitismus dulden
dafür werde er weiter kämpfen als
politiker und mensch
wir sind jetzt beim sport und bei katja
und corinna ist auch ein thema im
spitzensport heute abend josua kimmig er
ist erneut in corona quarantäne und
fehlt dem fc bayern daher im bundesliga
spiel heute abend in augsburg und nicht
nur seinetwegen wird diskutiert über die
impfpflicht für sport profisportler
für die profis ist es ein beruf für die
fans ist es freizeit das macht in sachen
impfen einen rechtlichen unterschied nur
genesene oder getestete zuschauer dürfen
ins stadion auf dem platz zählt zweig
noch nicht doch das wollen die
ministerpräsidenten nun ändern so der
konsens nach dem bund länder treffen
gestern
sehr schnell einig dass wenn zuschauer
im stadion zweig beachten müssen dass
das nach unserer auffassung auch für die
profis gelten soll das würde bedeuten
ungeimpfte spieler wie ohr sowie
chemisch dürften ihren beruf nicht mehr
ausüben rechtlich fragwürdig aktuell
wird chemisch den bayern zwei spiele
fehlen nachdem er kontakt zu einem
corona positiven hatte ich hoffe es ist
auch nicht ganz so schwer zu verstehen
dass die gefahr natürlich deutlich
größer ist als ungeimpfte mehr spiele
trainingseinheiten zu verpassen als das
kämpfte zur wahrheit gehört auch die
impfquote in der bundesliga liegt bei
gut 90 prozent ein wert von dem die
gesamtbevölkerung noch weit entfernt ist
jetzt ein fall aus china der für
verstörung sorgt denn kong trade tennis
profi und frühere hunderten gewinnerin
im doppel ist unauffindbar seit wochen
die sorge bei athleten sportverbänden
und fans wächst täglich
das sport idol aus china punkte ist
verschwunden weil sie etwas gemacht hat
was in china nicht sein darf in einem
online post beschuldigt sie den
ehemaligen vize-präsidenten der
kommunistischen partei jean paul ii sie
sexuell missbraucht zu haben weltweit
melden sich sportgrößen zu wort und
stellen eine frage wo ist
schockierend dass sie vermisst wird als
punk schwer ihre vorwürfe formulierte
wird sie damit gerechnet haben dass sie
von der bildfläche verschwindet denn in
china passiert das immer wieder in einem
brief der angeblich von ihr geschrieben
wurde bestreitet sie plötzlich alle
vorwürfe die skepsis steigt der chef des
frauentennis droht wir sind definitiv
bereit uns aus china zurückzuziehen und
werden uns allen komplikationen stellen
denn das hier ist größer als das
geschäft
die forderungen nach aufklärung werden
weltweit immer lauter diese stimmen kann
china nicht einfach verschwinden lassen
die ein starkes signal der wta die im
zweifel mehrere hundert millionen euro
dadurch verlieren wird man gespannt wird
diese geschichte weitergeht dankeschön
katja viele wolken etwas regen und ein
kleines bisschen sonne und wo erfahren
sie gleich von osten terry ich empfehle
noch das heute journal um 22 uhr mit
marietta slomka ihnen noch einen schönen
abend schön start ins wochenende
vielen dank und gerne morgen um 7 wieder
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der hoheluft druck
schwindet allmählich und wir bekommen
sie mit einem neuen tief zu tun dass
wandert von norden zu uns und bringt
dann regen mit hauptsächlich dann zum
abend aber trocken bleibt es dennoch
nicht denn in der nacht tröpfelt es hier
und da aus der dichten wolkendecke
es wird hauptsächlich springen seien
nach norden hin ist es trocken der wind
weht aus westlichen bis nordwestlichen
richtungen und ist teilweise stürmisch
im süden haben wir es mit nebel zu tun
ganz im süden kann es auch auflockern
und dann geht es bis auf minus zwei grad
runter ansonsten deutlich milder nach
norden mit zehn bis elf grad morgen
tagesverlauf weiterhin dichte bewölkung
vor allem im norden hier und da wieder
einige tropfen im süden durchaus auch
sonnenschein vor allem über den bergen
dort wo sich der nebel auflöst im
südwesten kann auch die sonne rauskommt
und das bei höchsten temperaturen von
fünf grad am alpenrand sonst 11 bis 12
grad im norden die kommenden tage am
sonntag setzt sich der regen allmählich
weiter richtung mitte durch den süden
durchaus sonnenschein vier bis elf grad
danach wird es kühler aber sonniger und
das bei temperaturen von 1 bis 9 grad
ein schöner